well the Religious Right was a movement
begun by political operatives not
religious leaders they had meetings and
there were dates and times and places
and they said we needed to mobilize a
constituency that is alienated that is
worried about the cultures direction
there they're not happy and they can be
mobilized in an effective block for the
sake of one political party that was
their intention and so there were
concerns about the sanctity of life and
the breakdown of family and and the kind
of the kind of corrosive culture I'm a
father with a eight year old and a four
year old and sometimes as a parent you
feel like parenting as a counter
cultural activity in America because
things are coming at your kids you know
a sexualized culture and had the agreed
the hedonism of materialism and said I
don't want my kids so a lot of people
say wait a minute something's happening
here so they had the heck could let it
legitimate concerns but it got
manipulated in my view and politicized
by an overtly political strategy and now
though that same constituency saying
wait a minute these aren't the only two
issues if we look at the Bible there are
two thousand verses in the Bible about
poor people about poverty climate change
is becoming a religious issue for a new
generation of angelica's they call it
creation care hiv/aids for a lot of
megachurch pastors is now a very big
concern Darfur the genocide in Darfur so
we're seeing a widening and deepening
beyond those two narrow agendas and even
there the sanctity of life applied not
just to abortion but to Darfur to to
where human rights are and human life
and dignities under assault so a
consistent ethic of life is now emerging
business so nearly 25
you